my name is Jonathan Devore I'm currently
a postdoctoral associate and appear at
the program in the growing studies and
i'm here to introduce our third panel
for the afternoon the title for which is
pigs in the city
alright um thank you for having me so
I'm going to talk to you today about two
campaigns to take care of our take get
rid of corrupt food and 1850s Manhattan
and there one was the 1858 swill milk
crisis you see some of those images on
the left side and then the 1859 piggery
war that came right after and they
differed markedly and I by comparing the
two I think we can get out how pigs were
treated differently from other animals
in the city and why that was a case so
both the swill milk days and the
piggeries took advantage of a lot of
waste in the city not unlike what we
were hearing in Cairo and they took care
of the successive food waste and turned
it into new food products in the case of
swill milk they were converting these
cows were converting distillery swill
and turning it into milk and meat and
swill was a combination of processed
corn barley and rye malt that was left
over from distilling liquors and beer
and by feeding the slops to two cows the
distilleries returning the remnants of
what was seen as a corrupted or
corruptible beverage into something that
was the purest of foods milk you could
feed it to babies yet this purity was
exactly what was most troubling this is
a map that was was produced I'm showing
where the distilleries were and though
the swill milk crisis came to a head in
1858 New York had been struggling with
the quality of its cow's milk for
decades by the 1830s several distillery
owners in Manhattan Brooklyn
Williamsburg and the Bronx had were
taking advantage of this idea that they
could they could have cows on their
property and pipe in the swill over to
some stables dairy production for large
cities like New York was complicated in
the 19th century this is before
refrigeration before you know
refrigerated railroad cars so you had to
have milk close enough to the city that
you can get it in without its spoiling
but it has to also had to be the cows
had to be far enough away from the city
that the farmer could
a Ford pastor but there was enough real
estate pressure to be pushing it away
and this was difficult you'd have milk
spoiling enroute to the city so so the
this was the seemed like a perfect
solution you could have the cows in the
city and they'd be taking care of waste
that would otherwise be dumped in the
rivers so here here's you know here's
this wasteful material feed it to the
cows you get milk it's closed in it's
going to be fed to New Yorkers and
there's no issue with spoilage but it
wasn't so simple cows this was hardly a
nutritious will was hardly nutritious
for the cows themselves when introduced
to the boiling liquid cows typically
balked and wouldn't want to eat it to
take a couple of days until desperation
would drive them to the slop a diet
consisting exclusively of swill led that
made the cows sick they would get sores
all over their bodies and their
condition their living conditions as
described in the 1850s were similar to
the Expos days that you see a factory
farms today they lived in cramped stalls
they never went outside they didn't have
very much ventilation the milk that the
cows produced was this blue bluish tint
it didn't look very good so what the
vendors did was they they adulterated it
they added a plaster of Paris they added
flour and eggs to make it look white and
thick and so this was hardly an
attractive led under nutritious beverage
and it was difficult this is before
labeling laws so it was difficult for
New Yorkers to know what they were
getting they'd buy their milk on the
corner from from carts or in Gregory and
groceries on the corners and the vendors
carts would say that it was Orange
County milk or Westchester milk or pure
country milk but it was actually coming
from sixteenth street or 39th Street and
poor regulation and enforcement kept the
business of dirty milk profitable and
viable well doctors and journalists had
long been calling for reform city
politicians ignored the newspapers
please until the 1858 when Frank Leslie
published his published his newspaper an
expose Frank Leslie's illustrated
newspaper
you've been seeing images from it here
was barely three years old but it would
come to really truly make its mark on
with this will milk expose unlike the
previous expose is in the New York Times
New York Herald and New York Tribune
Leslie's Leslie's articles were filled
with woodcut images and that ignited the
public and pressured previously
reluctant politicians to take on this
issue the visuals really made a
difference and the Irish the owners in
the dairy hands who were typically Irish
immigrants the owners weren't the owners
were wealthy native-born New Yorkers but
the the milkmaids as they recall even
though they were all men but that was a
gender thing that was thrown at them the
milkmaids were all Irish immigrants and
they knew the power of these images
immediately and they attacked at
leslie's artists and that's what you see
going on in this image here here so you
see the iris over here and they they
look you know kind of scraggly swine ish
sort of look to them a [ __ ] and here's
the the artist on the right side who's
come to to you know to for this
expedited to paint to draw what he was
seeing and he gets attacked with brick
bats and and stones and rocks and logs
are being thrown at him and you can in
you know there's there's even one man
who was interested in these articles
went to go to one of Brooklyn
distilleries and he was mistaken for an
artist and he was dealt quote a blow
between the the peepers be for being for
presumably being one of his artists so
this was simply not good for business
for the milk industry Frank Leslie
presented the images to the public but
not only opened their eyes to the sickly
appearance of the cows and the the
horrid conditions but also emphasized
the other nests of the people who are in
control of their food and you can see
the social costs an identity that that's
being an ethnicity that's being shown in
all these images the the the artist
seems refined the the Irish seem
bedraggled at best essentially brutish
untrustworthy and violent Outsiders had
control of their food and something had
to be done so when Leslie's expose
inspired a government investigation one
might have
tomb thats almost life was with limited
the public was enraged bad press was
inescapable and the pressure to close
down businesses was coming from left and
right from all these different
constituents but this this actually
didn't come to fruition that well so so
a committee of five alderman and
Councilman along with journalists toward
the cow sheds to at sixteenth Street in
239 Street and that the distillery
stables had advanced notice that they're
going to show up so they cleaned
everything up and they the the pullup
politicians took sips of milk and
watched a cow being slaughtered and
judged all of this and they then wrote a
report and the majority came out in
favor of swill milk saying actually it's
okay it tastes like regular milk a
couple of the the politicians declined
to sip the milk because they were a
little scared and and that with that it
was saved and Frank Leslie was livid he
published an illustration that you see
here alluding to the corruption behind
the swill milk and the corruption of a
three aldermen who came out in favor of
it in this image that as the aldermen
are whitewashing the stable you see you
see the the distillery owner putting
bags of money into their pockets and
there's it says five thousand dollars
over here and there's another one
hanging out of that guy's pocket and so
it showed that the these these
politicians were were United most maybe
not in politics or in social class but
and mostly in their willingness to
profit at the at the expense of public
good so despite this expose the
distilleries continued to operate for
several more decades pass pass this
expose but but they Leslie's work
however effectively directed the
public's attention to the the political
entanglements of food regulation in the
city and change the way that New Yorkers
viewed food that was created within the
city limits which takes us to the next
year which is the piggery war so with
all the attention given to the the
conversion of waste into food it seemed
almost inevitable that or a matter of
time until reformers eyes would turn
towards the offal boiling piggeries
uptown
bushman's for fattening pigs boiling and
grinding bones melting fat skinning and
rendering dead animals existed all over
the city especially in the Uptown rural
wards scattered emits the the clusters
of wooden shanties seen in the northern
parts of the city today with sub midtown
this is this is close to where if you
know New York this is close to where
Carnegie Hall is today and these these
they were scattered in mid sea shanties
and these large-scale piggies and
boiling establishments recycled
materials that many considered waste
recycle restaurant scraps carcasses
offal bones and blood and by refining
them for other industries and feeding
what was left over to the Hogs so they
would give bones to toothbrush
manufacturers and button makers and
fertilizer companies and with the food
waste that was so plentiful in the city
in New York was horribly unsanitary the
probably the poly their titles of trash
everywhere this was a way for trash to
be turned into protein and for it to be
recycled into other manufactured
materials so complaints about the Uptown
piggeries mounted as a city's footprint
started pushing further and further
north wealthy downtown neighbors refer
to this area as Hogtown pig town or
stink town and their disdain for
nuisances extended to the Irish
proprietors who owned them a writer for
The New York Times described the
neighborhood as a group of quote
shanties in which the pigs and the
patricks lie down miscellaneous ly while
their little ones of Celtic and swine of
origin combined and with billy goats
here and they're interspersed yeah the
the eye of increasing tie between the
proprietors ethnicities and the piggery
cemented the threat that both this
population and their hogs posts for
consumers and the inappropriateness of
their place in the city the pigs and the
Irish when politicians debated the
future of how town real estate values
came up again and again one politician
made an argument in support of
gentrification happening or that was
happening around hog town claiming that
the area was improving rapidly quote and
the people here wish to make it a
pleasant residence for those doing
business downtown as an uptown
neighborhood
around the developing Central Park were
rising in value the piggies were not
only becoming more visible but they're
also becoming more of a liability
concerted efforts to remove the
piggeries began in 1859 when a new new
city inspector was was appointed by the
mayor and he began his term by pressing
the health commissioner's to pass a new
law banning piggeries bone boiling and
offal boiling south of eighty-sixth
Street as soon as the commissioners of
Health approved the resolution that the
so-called piggery war began the troops
are made up of sanitary and health
inspectors as well as members of the
newly formed metropolitan police forces
this is the moment where the police are
professionalizing and they visited each
of the piggeries and gave all the
piggery owners three days notice to get
rid of all their materials the cauldrons
the Hogs the pens and if and then they
would return three days later and do it
themselves if any of that remained and
drive the pigs to the to the pound the
piggery owners had to act quickly to to
sell their there or relocate their
animals while residents did what they
could to hide the remaining hogs
sometimes concealing them among beds and
linens the police were persistent and
successful and the newspapers reveled in
stories of Irish biddies hiding hiding
pigs in their and their dresser drawers
this is a moment where domesticity is
being embraced by the middle class and
the idea that that these people would
bring pigs so close to their beds and
two into their homes just was it just
showed how how very far from normal the
Irish were when that while the piggery
owners often threaten the police the
little little violence actually occurred
women actually play the most violent
role here in one case my kind of
favorite story from the piggery wars
this was the one cases police at man
seized a hog by its its ears and then he
was confronted by this quote large
squarely built German woman with a large
tin pot and she whacked the officer with
the pot in a way that made him see stars
despite the police's power or maybe
perhaps because of it the newspapers
reveled in moments where they lost
control as you see here in this image
there's you know they highlighted scenes
where the Hogs ran between the police
officers officers legs toppling them
over or where where the police
desperately tried to hold onto a pigtail
and have it slip away or where police
were just so taken aback by the smell
that they they were holding all these
fabrics in front of their mouths just to
kind of make it through the piggeries
regardless of this chaos this was still
much more control than the city had ever
exhibited over the over the pigs or over
the environment in the city up until
this point the news what newspapers
portrayed the piggery war as a war for
the protection of the city's health and
prosperity journalists described the
immigrant proprietors as outsiders
threatening the city's health and
challenging its civility how could you
have a city be at once the nation's
metropolis but still have no control
over its public health its land use its
its food supply or even the practices of
its residents in almost every article
authors painted the pier Gary war and
triumphant triumphant terms they created
the police and health inspectors with
war heroes while describing the piggery
owners as ridiculous backwards stubborn
and defiant there's a lot of humor and
satin injected into these articles and
it was all basically poking fun at the
piggery owners unlike with most of the
thus will milk crisis where corrupt
politicians ultimately stood in the way
of active change reformers found true
success in the in the dramatic closing
of the piggies and it must have shocked
Norton New Yorkers to see their
government actually acting efficiently
here by if I September the the piggery
war was mainly over the city inspector
proudly reported that he had removed
9000 hogs whether by force or threat
demolished 3,000 pens and confiscated
100 boilers as one newspaper put it the
city had done a fearful amount of
laudable depredation so the recycling of
and repurposing of food food waste there
was an enormous industry in mid 19th
century New York City and because of its
vitality and prosperity as as well as
it's assumed threat to the city's public
health the the waste industries were
politically contentious the newspaper
exposes highlighted the difficulties and
dangers of urban food production
while while also striking fear among the
middle and upper classes that about the
immigrant outsiders who are entrusted
with their health and the quality of
their food so the big question here is
why was the government effectively
eliminating the the piggeries while
while preserving the the distillery
stables swill milk was notably a bigger
threat you know it given the widespread
use of cheap poor quality milk that by
all New Yorkers whether it was wise or
not there was high levels of infant
mortality at this time and it was being
blamed on swill milk this happened to
coincide with a moment where
breastfeeding was going out of style so
a lot of infants were were consuming
swill milk and they were dying babies
didn't rely on good quality pork they or
bacon for survival they it just wasn't
as much of a threat and yet this will
milk stayed and the reasons for this
include real estate pressure ethnic
stereotypes and political corruption so
that the complaints against this will
milk stables and the piggeries were
subtly different while anger over swill
milk was was more about unregulated
adulterated food threatening to sicken
unknowing consumers and sick and
children the most most complaints
against the piggeries focus less on poor
tasting pork although that came up once
or twice but more on the appropriate use
of land so close to Central Park the
piggies and the shanty towns that
surrounded them we had become a visible
sore on the image of the city for
instance reflecting back on the piggery
war and its success a writer for The New
York Herald wrote that it was quote
hardly possible to conceive that so much
abomination could have existed in a city
lit such as this as what was found in
the neighborhood of the beautiful
Central Park it is hardly credible and
it's recent and the recital of it is
positively sickening the city was in the
process of transforming and gentrifying
in a major way and the movement of
wealthy citizens and residents closer
uptown meant that piggeries and their
proprietors were being elbowed out of
the way the smells the public health
threats the unsightly pneus the fact
that the proprietors were less than a
respectable in the eyes of butuan New
Yorkers had left the the piggeries
vulnerable to attack this will milk
stables however didn't have the same
physical presence they were scattered in
less desirable areas and you needed a
map to know where they were you had to
publish a map because people just didn't
know
you'd pass the piggeries on stage
coaches uptown you would not see it if
you would not see the stables because
they were hidden behind walls but real
estate in markets market pressures can't
explain everything ethnic stereotyping
also in political corruption also played
major roles here now I'll admit there
were you know generalizations about
Irish in both cases but the owners of
the distillery stables were these
wealthy native-born New Yorkers who had
enough money to release way the the
politicians so Frank Leslie fuming about
the persistence of the swill Milt
stables a year after the expose wrote
that despite that swill not being more
dangerous quote the poor owners of the
piggeries are thus punished while the
wealthy owners of the swill stables
escaped with impunity perhaps if they
had more wealth and political and
influence like the distillery owners the
piggeries would have remained longer
ultimately this is a story not only
about poor food regulation but also
about environmental and justices and the
unequal policing of certain nuisances
over others zooming out this is a period
in New York New York's history where did
the city's beginning to embrace an early
form of Zoning industries and land uses
that were seen as incompatible with
residential neighborhoods are getting
pushed further and further from the
edges of the city the so-called rural
wards where the piggeries were located
were transforming and the pigs were a
smelly visible presence of standing in
the way of gentrification and
transformation New York was starting a
new chapter in this area and which would
involve redefining the neighborhood and
what land uses were appropriate in the
metropolis through selective targeting
of certain nuisances though you can see
how the inequalities were inherent in
this process to draw to segregate the
uses of the city so the modernization of
a city can seem like a set a series of
positive improvements addressing serious
public health threats transportation
problems increasing civic cities
livability and efficiency yet the
process of taking control of the city
was incomplete messy and notably uneven
and it was tangled up in corrupt
politics and it affected people and
urban animals and dramatically different
degrees reinforcing social inequities
and it's in this moment in the mid 90
cendri this is where you're seeing kind
of a definition of what it meant to be
urban and what we're pigs or other
animals are allowed and that urban
definition or not these were the
boundaries are being being drawn thank
you so we have five minutes questions
for Katherine then we can open it up to
a broader discussion hi I was really
interesting i work on Antebellum
agricultural reforms that i was super
interesting that i was wondering where
you if this fits in a where it fits into
these discussions that are going on
around the same time about how to get
city wastes back to farms to deal with
but the soil depletion problem so
there's there's a lot of people we're
talking about this in 18 feet and not
just in the US but in France and right
Paris right so you know that did that
these systems need to be put in place to
get all the waste out of the city and
back to these farms and so at first
glance it seems like this like swim milk
is a kind of like that's exactly what
they're trying to do so I'm just curious
where it fits into that yes so it's all
about who's making the money in that
situation because the there this is this
all comes out of my book taming
Manhattan I actually have a chapter
that's all about the waste recycling
also human waste and animal waste
because it's being processed there's the
poudre factories that are outside of new
york and new jersey that are processing
human ways and powdering it and making
it kind of benign enough that they can
then sell it as like a guano substitute
to local focal forms but yet so this is
kind of it there's waste happening here
and you want to have that recycling but
they don't want this they don't want it
so close to the city and there's another
attempt to get rid of this offal that
was being fed to the pigs that was that
the basically the city wanted or 11 city
inspector I want to take it on as a that
for private a private contractor to get
in the hands of someone wealthy enough
to position it far from the city and
ship it down over there and and then
they could make money off it yeah
there's a very corrupt deal where he was
actually making all the money but yeah
so it was about the control he wanted it
out of the
the the Irish's hit the Irish and German
hands and instead put into the to a
contract where one person could benefit
or one company could benefit exclusively
so it's yeah it's not entirely in the
same system of the manure that's being
circled out to the the or the too late
to Long Island in Westchester and
Connecticut but it's kind of a separate
recycling good yeah it's all kind of
yeah there's there some if not it's not
a very comprehensive plan that they have
I guess yeah it's interesting that you
say it's a demonstrates the urbanization
as process of zoning but and then it
seems it's really that in direct
relationship to that it's also about
urban places as sites of property and
and I'm curious I mean you can see how
swill milk survives by patronage and
contract and what I'm curious about is
how the folks that own the piggeries got
access to them how did they what was how
they how do they control the piggeries
where were they were they immigrant
communities in fact and coming in you
know was it was it a routine kind of you
know hosting industry that would that
would bring in guest worker certain
things like that no no these are small
scale of proprietors they were typically
they were typically Irish were German
immigrants who came in but it was
scattered amidst a bunch of shanty towns
and so people would take it up either
informally they weren't large-scale some
of the more large-scale and people owned
like a lot of processing materials but
it was mostly small scale use had a pen
and cauldron and that was basically the
gist of it and sometimes they were there
were actually literally squatters where
they're on the uptown Manhattan was
pretty rocky and you had to have black
you had to get to a point where you
though you can afford to pay the city to
lay the streets and and then also if
there wasn't real estate pressure you
wouldn't blast down the the block to
meet the street level so they were up
high on the schist and in kind of in
marginal land essentially so some people
were squatters some people had informal
leases with the landowners and they were
just kind of in a sort of hodgepodge
situation yeah we have a we can do one
more question for cath and then we'll
open it up to a more general discussion
yeah hey that's a totally great paper
and I want to know if you had more to
say about the relationship with us to
transitions and market culture at the
same time these food crises are going on
there's a reorganization of New York's
kind of retail market systems that you
know Thomas DeVoe talks about in the
market assistant and the books kind of
about how New Yorkers were getting their
food is there a connection on that side
of it as well I guess on the retail
consumer side as well as this
environmental side yeah so you see the
the growth of whereas you are you seeing
the growth of butchers small butcher
shops that are out in the outskirts of
the city and its I don't think it's an
impact it's not impacted by the piggery
wherever I made sure it wasn't impacted
by the Perry but for the general
devolution at one point new york city
had these big markets public markets and
all the butcher's had to have stalls in
these public markets and this in the
middle of the 19th century you start to
see that sort of withering away where
these become more wholesale markets and
the butchers are either first illegally
and then with with approval opening up
small butcher shops throughout the rest
of the city and that's where you're
getting a lot of the cheap meat so a lot
of this pork is being processed in those
small scale butchers and in fact in that
that map let me see if I can pull it up
with us making you see a small butcher
shop down the lower left-hand corner
what's this is part of the expose
because they were saying all the
horrible yes we'll meet is going to be
processed and that butcher shop and look
how this is you know the smoking gun
that that was happening so you're
getting bad meat on the market too but
again there's no good labeling so you
kind of know if a butcher is serving
cheap me then it's probably coming from
these sources from the the bad the kind
of poorly kept cows or from the pigs
that are fed on the garbage
you
you